تتنافس الدول لانتاج كميات كبيره من
الحليب لتلبيه احتياجات السوق كونه يدخل
في العديد من المنتجات الغذائيه تعتبر
الولايات المتحده هي اكبر دوله منتجه في
العالم لحليب البقر بنحو 103 ملايين طن
سنويا وهي الاولى ايضا في حجم استهلاك
الحليب وفي تصنيع منتجاته الثانويه الهند
هي ثاني اكثر البلدان انتاجا للحليب بسبعه
وتسعين مليون طن سنويا اذ تنتج اكثر من 9%
من حجم الانتاج العالمي للحليب الصين تاتي
ثالثه ب 39 طنا سنويا وتصدر الصين حليبها
فقط الى عدد قليل جدا من البلدان الاسيويه
يوجد في الصين ما يقرب من سته ملايين و600
الف بقره من سلاله ابقاره هولشتاين التي
يتم استيرادها على مر السنين يخططون الان
لانشاء قطيع ابقار في غضون سنتين الى ثلاث
وتستثمر بكثافه هذه الاقار لبناء مزرعه
البان من مئه الف بقره
[موسيقى]